[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du 7-8 loisirs
toutes vos idées sorties dans le
département on commence avec le sommaire
nous parlerons de la programmation du
théâtre de la grange à bois d'arcy le
maire adjoint de la ville en charge de
la culture nous parlera de miss
carpenter avec marianne james et du
groupe de folk nara gogniat carte est à
elancourt les femmes pilotes sont à
l'honneur jusqu'au 17 mars une
exposition leur est consacrée des
pionnières aux astronautes
reportage à suivre et se prendre pour un
dj y composer ses propres morceaux
électro c'est possible avec les ateliers
du labo numérique vélizy mais annie
poker nous donnera plus de précisions
dans le rendez-vous junior mais on
commence avec le festival à tout bout de
champ de magny les hameaux il débute
mardi prochain avec au programme
exposition et une vingtaine de
spectacles et ce jusqu'au 26 mars
mercredi un trio rock n roll pour les
enfants se produira sur la scène de
l'estany né ce sont les biskotos et on
est produit un extrait
y'en a jamais trop
il en faut encore
il en faut encore vous rêvez plus fort
plus haut
[Musique]
pour rêver plus fondants
v pluie ou et demain au prisme
d'elancourt partez pour un voyage dans
les rêveries d'un petit garçon
hospitalisé
la légende du magicien bleu est un
spectacle familial entre réel et
imaginaire
il est organisé par le lion's club de
l'encours au profit d'un jeune handicapé
l'argent récolté servira à financer le
don d'un chien d'assistance un animal
d'une valeur de 15 mille euros on écoute
les précisions de jean claude sénéchal
le président du club
on appelle ça l'assistance animalière
c'est effectivement très très très
profitable à un certain nombre de
pathologies
bon il ya évidemment les aveugles et
c'est comme ça que le lion ce club est
connu pour les chiens guides d'aveuglés
mais pas uniquement c'est également très
très très utile pour les autistes les
jeunes autistes
alors c'est un spectacle qui mélange un
petit peu tout il ya du théâtre et du
chant est une équipe de gospel il ya de
la danse et nous recevons aujourd'hui
j'enfilais plus maire adjoint en charge
de la culture à bois d'arcy il va nous
parler des prochains spectacles à venir
au théâtre de la grange bonjour jean
filles dans leurs habits et les
prochains spectacles ça commence dès
samedi prochain samedi 18 mars vous
accueillez marianne james dans la peau
de miss carpenter alors qu'elle est ce
spectacle c'est timide carpenter bas
c'est un spectacle tête d'affiche de la
saison qu'on a et on est vraiment très
heureux de recevoir donc le samedi 18 à
20h30
c'est un spectacle totalement loufoque
humoristique mais surtout évidemment
beaucoup de champ donc elle incarne un
nouveau personnage dix ans après le
fameux bien connu qu'on avait vu avant
et donc elle va débarquer sur la scène
de la grange a tremblé avec ses trois
golden boy et et
ait présenté tout en humour et en
musique spectacles variés tout public
est très intéressant et alors son
personnage alors qui est elle cette noce
carpenter c
c'est une diva un peu nan c'est une
c'est une diva qui a eu un parcours
historique est assez important et qui
avait envie de reprendre la lumière et
donc elle va tout au long du spectacle
retrouvez cette lumière à travers un
nouveau personnage très passionnant et
très intéressant et vous me disiez un
spectacle un peu loufoque alors je pense
qu'on se rende contre un petit peu de
toute la démesure du personnage de mr
painter le mieux c'est qu'on regarde un
court extrait et on se retrouve juste
après est ce que vous savez qui je suis
non ce n'est pas andré carpentier ses
cartons mais je vous fais la mémoire
d'une certaine idée d'hollywood qui
aurait disparu l'accablement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors on l'a vu c'est un personnage
vraiment ou en couleur c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire il ya beaucoup
d'humour également dans ce spectacle oui
beaucoup d'humour
c'est une sorte de comédie musicale
c'est burlesque harry peu de personnages
sur scène évidemment irak lé c3 sexy
golden boy mais c'est vrai la comédie
musicale comme on les aime et qui va
être très sympa ou alors justement ce
côté comédie musicale il ya également
les différents morceaux qui hérite remet
tout le spectacle le tout la santé de la
prestation en fait exactement c'est
différents thèmes différents passages
différents moments avec des haches fois
des thématiques différentes et des
sonorités aussi parfois très active nous
tous un peu moins mais c'est très
passionnant mais ça s'adresse à tout le
monde même les plus jeunes peuvent venir
comprendre l'humour voix et globalement
c'est un spectacle tout public qui qui
devrait attirer beaucoup de monde
d'ailleurs la salle et est presque plein
il reste encore quelques places donc
n'hésitez pas à venir mais oui c'est
tout public quoique très bien enfin
faudra pas hésiter à réserver du coup et
on va parler musique folk
à présent c'est le 23 mars c'est le
nargue au niakhar tête qui va monter sur
les planches de la grange exactement
dans le cadre de nos cafés concerts le
jeudi soir donc là quelques jours après
la saint patrick
un groupe il ya un quatuor qui arrive
avec une sonorité irlandaise mais pas
que et qui avait que de la mandole du
violon
et la guitare à faire bouger cette salle
de la grange de sur des thématiques
verra pour le coup assez différent de
miss carpenter mais thématique fait fête
de la saint-patrick dynamique et surtout
très très très chaleureux c'est très
dansant également qu est ce qu il ya de
l'accordéon et du violon de la cornemuse
c'est aussi fait pour danser enfin par
balle quelques pas j'espère que les gens
pousseront les tables et les chaises et
se mettront à danser en effet ce n'est
pas ben balle mais ça a vocation à être
dense henry il mêle différentes
influences également un peu musique de
l'est ce genre de choses alors oui c'est
c'est un mélange assez éclectique de
différentes origines est un peu
sonorités irlandaises aussi comme
j'étais tout à l'heure c'est très
original c'est donc notre directeur de
la culture qui ne la mise 1
programmation et c'est passionnant
on a et on va voir un spectacle qui est
un format assez court comme les cafés
les cafés concerts mais qui devrait bien
faire bien fonctionner alors justement
pourquoi avoir voulu les programmes et
c'est cette richesse qui voulut qui vous
a plu voix à bois d'arcy pour les faire
venir à l'occasion de la saint-patrick
est exactement en fait tout au long de
la saison les cafés concerts on essaie à
chaque fois d'avoir des sonorités de
paix ou des thématiques est assez
différente et la c1 catoire assez
complet qui apportent des choses assez
différentes que le coût de trio on a eu
encore quelques semaines c c'est
vraiment un sujet à part ces musiques à
part et ça c est de ça devrait être très
sympathique et on finit par une dernière
date alors là c'est le 25 mars et là
c'est un peu plus pour les littéraires
avec la rencontre de l'écrivain marc
trévidic exactement cette année on a
lancé en fait les le prix des lecteurs à
bois d'arcy donc c'est tout au long de
la saison
un fil rouge avec des catégories jeunes
publics et adultes et donc on fait
rencontrer les auteurs avec les
artisiens et des habitants des communes
aux alentours qui veut venir et là on a
le plaisir de re soir marc trévidic qui
viendra échanger avec les avec les gens
sur son livre à la main qui vient pas à
traiter des problématiques du printemps
arabe et de la montée de l'intégrisme en
tunisie ont tout à fait d'actualité
également malheureusement en tout cas
merci beaucoup
jean-philippe plus des troubles sur
notre plateau du 7-8 loisirs nous a
reparlé de vos prochains spectacles et
donc toutes les dates que nous venons
d'évoquer on le rappelle sont à
retrouver sur le site internet de la
commune merci beaucoup j'en fis et dans
le cadre de la journée des droits de la
femme célébrée
le 8 mars la ville d'elancourt propose
une exposition sur le thème des femmes
pilotes
une manière de rendre hommage à ces
figures moins connu que leurs homologues
masculins
plus de précisions dans ce reportage
cinq fois détentrice du record mondial
féminin de vitesse dans les années 50
jacqueline auriol a marqué le monde de
l'aviation elle est la première femme
pilote d'essais de france ça se passait
au servette brétigny à l'époque et donc
il n'y avait pas encore tous les
ordinateurs et donc les avions étaient
testés en réalité pas sur des
ordinateurs
donc on fait tous les tests à partir
d'avions et donc elle était dans les
pilotes d'essais donc il fallait qu elle
est une formation d'ingénieur si vous
voulez parce qu'après dans les essais
vous avez un compte rendu à faire des
explications à des professionnels et
donc elle est partie sur des petits
avions elle a terminé sur les avions de
chasse une figure incontournable comme
toutes les femmes présentées ici à
elancourt c'est pas nous retrace leur
histoire des pionnières aux astronautes
des métiers autrefois réservés aux
hommes
une exposition mise en place par michel
bond enseigne est ancienne compétitrice
là je suis dans la tenue de l'avion sur
lequel j'ai fait les championnats de
france de voltige et là je suis en photo
devant et broad où j'ai gagné le premier
prix du rallye du dauphiné on a le
sentiment d'avoir encore des gens qui
pensent que c'est pas accessibles aux
femmes
avec cette exposition on essaie de la
faire circuler dans toute la france pour
bien faire voir que il ya de tout et que
c'est ouvert à tout le monde
selon son association aujourd'hui les
femmes ne représentent que 7% des
pilotes professionnels la conquête des
droits des femmes passe aussi par la
conquête du ciel mélanie poker nous a
rejoint pour notre rendez-vous junior de
la semaine et on va parler électro
bonjour mélanie bonjour camille de la
musique électro plus précisément parce
qu'en fait la ville de versailles
tout ne fait pas mais c'est le berceau
de la french touch un des groupes
français les plus célèbres et versailles
et air alors le week-end dernier il ya
eu le festival électro chic avec
plusieurs concerts meadows il y a aussi
des ateliers dont celui de faire son
propre morceau de musique électro
c'était la médiathèque de vélizy et vous
pouvez y faire de la musique assistée
par ordinateur la mae
la mae donc c'est pour la musique
simplement le fait de produire de la
musique
via un outil numérique qu'en
l'occurrence un ordinateur et avec
derrière un logiciel on a une partie
mixage on va avoir tous les éléments qui
il choisit
donc les instruments pour choisi on va
utiliser et ensuite une partie
séquençage on va dire pour tel
instrument tu vas jouer de telles notes
je vais jouer tel rythmique mixage
séquence assez comment sage rythmique ça
semble un peu compliqué quand même un
peu barbare qui peut suivre cet atelier
beaucoup de monde ça commence dès 10 ans
ça paraît compliqué ce qu'on fait ce
sont des mots qu'on n'utilise pas tous
les jours mais comme tout découverte
d'une activité il faut de la patience
alors dans cet asile et une partie qu'on
va appeler prise en main du logiciel
c'est presque le plus barbare avec le
logiciel on choisit son instrument le
rythme qu'on veut lui donner qu'il soit
rapide lent faire des boucles et ensuite
on descend les éléments sur une timeline
je le disais ça peut se faire dès 10 ans
lors de ce premier atelier étaient une
dizaine à s'y être essayé mais ça
s'adresse aussi aux plus grandes voix
l'image s'appelle dylan lui l'a 20 ans
mais ça faisait longtemps qu'ils
voulaient composer ses propres morceaux
écoutez le j'ai vraiment envie d'aller
et il sait
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment une
expérience inoubliable une expérience
innovante une nouvelle expérience pour
moi et ça me plaît de réaliser ça je
voulais faire une formation et le dj
mais j'avais pas les bases ils n'avaient
pas les bases mais là avec avec cette
expérience qui fait un an que je viens
de découvrir cet atelier bah je me dis
peut-être laissé un beau symbole
premiers débuts pour pouvoir être dj
après pour faire des mixes et où trois
autres ateliers sont prévus le mercredi
et les samedis suivants au labo
numérique de vélizy merci beaucoup mais
l'allié donc tout pour devenir peut-être
les nouveaux faits ni sur les nouveaux
horaires on l'espère en tout cas
les informations sont à retrouver sur le
site internet
et c'est maintenant l'heure de notre un
jardin avec encore quelques rendez vous
à ne pas manquer et il y aura du sport
ce week end et plus précisément du
baseball le plus grand club de france
celui de montigny le bretonneux les
cougars affrontera sa vie ni un match
amical pour se mettre en appétit et
lancer la saison ce sera dimanche à 11
heures et ce soir commence la 2e édition
du festival du bruit qui pensent trois
concerts de musique classique sont
organisées jusqu'à dimanche sur le site
de port royal des champs
c'est la fin de ce set 8 loisirs je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivis et je vous
retrouve vendredi prochain pour un
nouveau numéro et je vous souhaite un
excellent week end
[Musique]